reino unido salió oficialmente del
mercado único y de la unión aduanera
abandonando definitivamente la órbita de
la unión europea y adentrándose en un
período repleto de incertidumbre es el
primer ministro británico por lee
johnson envió un mensaje confiando en
que el 2001 traerá libertad al país
ya es año nuevo en el 'viejo continente'
europa recibe el 2021 en medio de un
auge de los contagios y fuertes
restricciones por el joven 19 aunque con
la esperanza de aplacar el virus con la
vacuna el presidente francés emmanuel
macrón advirtió que los próximos meses
serán muy difíciles y mientras tanto
también entre celebraciones reducidas a
su mínima expresión en el continente
americano socialista para darle la
bienvenida al 2021 california se
convirtió en el tercer estado
estadounidense en superar las 25 mil
muertes mientras que en mexico la
ocupación hospitalaria llega al 85%
hola muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 muchísimas gracias
por acompañarnos como siempre soy
santiago ariztía y comenzamos esta
emisión en reinounido que abandonó de
manera oficial los últimos lazos que lo
ligaban a la unión europea con el fin
del denominado periodo de transición se
abra ahora un nuevo capítulo repleto de
incertidumbres en el break city con la
salida del reino unido- del mercado
único y la unión aduanera a partir de
ahora a londres y bruselas deberán tener
un entendimiento bajo nuevas reglas tras
un acuerdo alcanzado in extremis en
nochebuena decenas de personas
lamentaron este suceso congregándose de
frente a la embajada británica en la
capital belga para realizar una vigilia
y el primer ministro británico boris
johnson por su parte expresó su
optimismo en que a partir del 2021 reino
unido- entre en una nueva etapa definida
por mayor libertad independencia y
crecimiento
este es un momento increíble para este
país tenemos nuestra libertad en
nuestras manos y depende de nosotros
aprovecharla al máximo y creo que será
el instinto abrumador de la gente de
este país al unirse como un reino unido
inglaterra escocia gales e irlanda del
norte trabajando juntos para expresar
nuestros valores en todo el mundo
lideraremos tanto el g7 como la cumbre
sobre el cambio climático con 26 en
glasgow y una gran bretaña global y
abierta generosa que mira hacia afuera
internacionalista y de libre comercio
2021 es el año en que podemos hacerlo y
creo que 2021 es sobre todo el año en el
que finalmente haremos esas cosas
cotidianas que ahora parecen perdidas en
el pasado post el post mientras tanto de
europa se le dio la bienvenida al año
2021 y lo hizo en medio de fuertes
rebrote por la pandemia de coronavirus
kobe 19 en diversos países reino unido
por ejemplo registró en la última
jornada del año casi 56 mil contagios
19 y 964 muertes entretanto españa
registró 18.000 nuevos casos y 148
fallecidos por su parte del presidente
de francia y manuel macro me dijo que
los primeros meses de 2021 serán
difíciles en referencia a la pandemia
aunque concentró sus esperanzas en el
efecto de las vacunas el mandatario
también rindió honor a los 64 mil
fallecidos que deja hasta el momento de
la pandemia en el país en 2021 sin
importar lo que ocurra sabremos
enfrentarnos a las crisis sanitarias
económicas sociales terroristas
climáticas que no se van a apagar este
primero de enero los primeros meses de
un próximo año serán difíciles y al
menos durante un tiempo la epidemia se
mantendrá como un gran peso sobre la
vida de este país en 2021 sin importar
lo que pase porque estamos preparados
también sabremos enfrentarnos a los
retos por venir la transición ecológica
y la protección de la biodiversidad con
las propuestas de la convención
ciudadana y con otras reformas
la lucha por la república y por nuestros
valores el laicismo y la hermandad la
fraternidad el más seguridad
paul y nuestro compromiso por el mérito
el trabajo la higuerita de jong la
igualdad de oportunidades y la lucha
contra todas las inequidades y las
discriminaciones entre tanto américa
latina superó durante esta semana la
barrera de los 500 mil muertos por el
virus del cobach 19 una situación que
mantiene a varios países de la región
con restricciones en medio de estas
celebraciones de año nuevo de hecho este
mismo jueves no se va a permitir el
acceso a las playas para ver los
tradicionales fuegos artificiales en el
río de janeiro en brasil y mientras
tanto en eeuu california termina el año
2020 como el tercer estado del país en
sobrepasar los 25 mil fallecidos con
propia les nos lleva por este recorrido
del continente americano
no es extraño ver un tráfico pesado en
los ángeles por estas fechas pero esta
es una fila de autos con personas
esperando para hacerse el test de kobe
19 y es que california vive por estos
días un incremento crítico de
hospitalizaciones este estado registró
su primer caso de joven 19 en enero a
los 10.000 muertos se llegó en agosto y
este 31 de diciembre se sobrepasaron los
25 mil decesos por el nuevo coronavirus
nueva york ya superó esa barrera y hoy
la gran manzana restringirá el acceso al
times square a un puñado de invitados
para que vean los juegos pirotécnicos en
américa latina' el 2019 también se
recibirá con restricciones desde el 18
de diciembre y hasta el 10 de enero
ciudad de méxico suspendió la actividad
de los negocios no esenciales con una
saturación de la ocupación hospitalaria
que llega al 85 por ciento creo que nos
toca suerte y llegamos y entró por así
decirlo rápido pero nada más el tema es
que pues no hay camas la tenían sentada
con oxígeno
creo que esperando a que se escapara en
río de janeiro no se reúnirán los cerca
de 3 millones de personas que suelen
congregarse cada año para el espectáculo
de pirotecnia el acceso a las playas se
bloqueó en medio de la denominada
segunda ola de contagio y coincidiendo
con los primeros casos de la nueva
variante en colombia el gobierno terminó
el año con el anuncio de la compra de 9
millones de dosis de la vacuna
desarrollada por johnson y johnson en el
país cafetero las regiones han adoptado
restricciones que van desde toques de
queda hasta la ley seca para prohibir la
venta de alcohol en perú la pandemia
golpea con una de las tasas de
mortalidad más altas del mundo y tras
una crisis política de ahí que más de
uno quiera sobre todo cumplir con la
tradición de los baños de florecimiento
un ritual para entrar limpio al año
nuevo
y en otras noticias el gobierno de china
aprobó su primera vacuna para el uso
público contra el cob y 19 desarrollada
por una filial de la farmacéutica
estatal scinopharm la aprobación que es
condicionada dado que aún faltan algunos
estudios clínicos se produce
precisamente un día después de que sheen
of arms anunciara que la vacuna tiene
una efectividad del 79.3 por ciento
china planea inocular a 50 millones de
personas con vacunas nacionales antes de
las celebraciones del año nuevo lunar en
febrero hablamos de una de las
migraciones humanas más grandes de todo
el planeta
de noticias de medio oriente vamos ahora
a yemen porque aviones de guerra de la
coalición apoyada por arabia saudita
atacaron al menos 15 puntos en la
capital saná esta manera de retaliación
tras los bombardeos que sacudieron el
aeropuerto de adén y varios sitios de la
ciudad el pasado miércoles el gobierno
de coalición acusó a los rebeldes hutíes
que controlan buena parte del norte del
país del ataque en el que murieron al
menos 22 personas el jefe de gabinete
yemení aseguró que el ine atentado
habrían participado expertos iraníes
y el tribunal superior de hong kong
ordenó que el magnate de los medios
similares vuelva a ser detenido
argumentando que el juez cometió un
error en la decisión de dejarlo en
libertad bajo fianza recordemos que la
está acusado bajo la ley de seguridad
nacional impuesta por china buscando
frenar meses de manifestaciones
prodemocracia en el territorio el fallo
del tribunal de apelación final se
produce una semana después de que el
empresario fuera liberado con una fianza
de un millón trescientos mil dólares
avanzamos con noticias de américa
latina' y vamos a ecuador donde
comenzaron oficialmente las campañas
electorales para los comicios
presidenciales de este país previstos
para el 7 de febrero de 2021 las
campañas comienzan con un récord
histórico de 16 candidatos que a partir
de hoy intentarán convencer a los
ecuatorianos de que les den sus votos
unos 13 millones de ciudadanos están
habilitados para participar en estas
elecciones que definirán quién será el
sucesor del presidente de lenin moreno
quien gobernará el país sudamericano
hasta el próximo 24 de mayo
y cada vez son más las naciones que le
dan la bienvenida al año nuevo en medio
de la pandemia de kobe 19 capitales
europeas como por ejemplo moscú y atenas
festejaron usar la llegada de 2021 con
fuegos artificiales también lo hicieron
varias ciudades orientales como por
ejemplo usan en china taipei en taiwán y
dubai en medio oriente en bangkok
tailandia se lanzaron 20.000 fuegos
artificiales ecológicos que fueron
fabricados a base de arroz
con estas imágenes nos despedimos pero
no sin antes por supuesto desearles en
nombre de todo france24 un muy feliz año
nuevo
[Música]